[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt einen richtig coolen
herzhaften snack wer meine sendung auf
fox gesehen hatte einfach sehr lebt der
hat vielleicht dort schon mal gesehen
und zwar mache ich heute apfel rosen und
viele kennen diese apfel rosen in
blätterteig als süßes bisher
ich mache es aber jetzt herzhaft als
richtig coolen snack mit sauerkraut und
röstzwiebeln drin also richtig richtig
cool und vor allem wenn ihr zum beispiel
mal spontan jemanden zu gast habt dann
könnt ihr die wirklich super schnell
vorbereiten
ihr könnt sie auch toll mitnehmen die
kammer warm und kalt essen und die sind
echt immer gesagt mach unbedingt dieses
rezept für deinen kanal und heute kommen
ich zeige mich mal eben kurz die zutaten
ich verwende dafür sechs bis acht kleine
rote äpfel die habe ich etwas
zitronensaft crème fraiche ich habe ich
sauerkraut aus der dose röstzwiebeln
salz und pfeffer und blätterteig nehme
ich den apfel und nehmen ihnen das
kerngehäuse raus so passiert in der
mitte ein loch habt ihr selbst wird es
[Musik]
und jetzt nämlich hier direkt eine
schüssel mit drachen und da kommt ein
bisschen zitronensaft rein damit die
äpfel nicht braun werden
ihr könnt im prinzip auch direkt dem
topf nehmen denn danach kommen die äpfel
noch mal ganz kurz in den topf ich mache
jetzt nur nicht mit ihr ist einfach
schön sehen könnt in der glasschüssel
und jetzt die app für ganz bayern hof so
fein wie es nur geht normalerweise würde
ich das jetzt einfach hinnimmt alles
schneider machen da geht es nämlich
super schnell aber ich zeige euch wie es
hier auch ganz einfach mit einer
einfachen hobel geht erst mal die beste
einstellung ich machen wir gerne oben
und unten erst mal gerade dem dann kann
ich den rest erhalten
[Musik]
nämlich die äpfel und manche sind ja
jetzt ganz und manche sind nur halbe
ringe denn am anfang erstmal immer nur
diese halben ringe
damit schneidet hier unten einfach so
ein bisschen gerade weg den part nicht
wegschmeißen
den können wir einfach essen die anderen
werden einfach halbiert und hab ich
nämlich direkt zwei schöne sowie ist
[Musik]
jetzt geht's ans füllen der apfel rosen
neben den blätterteig und bin ich jetzt
nicht gerade auf fertigen wettert
zurückgreifen wollen können dir denn
entweder selber machen oder hat es auch
schon mit pizzateig macht es war auch
echt gut und jetzt schneidet den in vier
streifen
das können die renterinnen pizza rad
machen oder zum beispiel mit so einem
bissigen so habe ich gleich vier
gleichmäßige streifen
[Musik]
dann mit dem fresh bestreichen
ein bruch dieser zutaten hier macht mich
richtig hungrig jetzt mit salz und
pfeffer bestreuen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt depp hat also beim nächsten
jetzt die äpfel richtig schön dünn
gehobelt falls ihr sie nicht ganz so
dünn bekommt dann könnt ihr die äpfel
mit dem zitronenwasser einfach ein
bisschen kochen so etwa ein bis zwei
minuten blanchieren damit die äpfel ein
bisschen fähig sein werden aber hier
sieht man jetzt ganz gut die sind
richtig schön biegsam und flexibel und
gebrechen dann auch nicht beim aufrollen
und jetzt die apfelspalten nehmen und
hier oben so ein bisschen leicht
überlappend auf den teig geben
das müsste auch von oben nach unten
arbeiten immer schön sauber arbeiten
ich meine natürlich abzuschreiben sind
akkus balken zum abgespalten kommen
je kleiner die apple sind umso mehr
rosenblätter hat später die rose damit
kommt jetzt das sauerkraut dran und ich
weiß manche mögen sauerkraut nicht ob
ich hier drinnen es ist wirklich ganz
ganz ganz lecker und falls ihr doch sagt
ich will lieber die süße variante machen
dann könnt ihr einfach sauerkraut in
roßleben weglassen und zum beispiel ein
bisschen vanille extrakten puderzucker
in die creme fraiche einrühren und dann
ebenso ein
aber ich sag's euch einen versuch ist es
wert ist echt super lecker und alle die
ihr seid ihr abgeschossen probiert haben
die haben gesagt es schmeckt sehr gut
so jetzt röstzwiebeln ihr könnt auch
frische zwiebel nehmen und die schneiden
aber röstzwiebeln hat schon dieses rost
aroma
deswegen sind die echt lecker jetzt ganz
wichtig hier unten den part den habe ich
ausgelassen mit den jetzt darüber legen
sodass das sauerkraut und die
röstzwiebeln so ein bisschen wie so ein
bisschen eingepackt werden und das
bewirkt dass unten gleich beim backen da
nix ausläuft ihr könnt jetzt theoretisch
auch eine ganz grosse tag machen und ihr
macht so wie ich kleine muffins deswegen
halte ich die jetzt denn so groß würden
die nicht in die mav in form passen
und jetzt vorsichtig von der einen seite
her aufrollen
auf was sind das nicht ausfällt und dann
entsteht so schon die erste große jetzt
habe ich hier ein backblech
das bestätigt jetzt mit back trance gray
und jetzt einfach rein legen und die
restlichen auch auf rollen und ich habe
sie übrigens die apfelsorte red prince
rap richtige hab ich vorher auch noch
nie gesehen
und manchmal habe ich kleine rote äpfel
da brauche ich dann sechs bis acht jetzt
komm ich bisher mit drei äpfeln ganz gut
aus zumal die echt groß waren
deswegen müsste da einfach gucken am
besten am anfang erstmal nicht so viele
äpfel aufschneiden und dann einfach
schauen ob sie ausreichen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr auch gerne
noch ein bisschen aufpeppen und zum
beispiel speck mit rein leben oder auch
sukuk in kleine würfel geschnitten und
dann mit darzulegen
dann habt ihr noch ein bisschen fleisch
drin aber der mutter liebt diese krone
sind
[Musik]
und dann können die apfel rosen schon
gebacken werden wenn ihr beide fläche
gleichzeitig fertig habt einfach weiß
luft packen und weideflächen ofen
schieben oder eben kurz nacheinander
der apfel rosen sind jetzt gebacken und
die lassen sich auch echt ganz gut raus
lösen und dann kommen die hersteller
jetzt auf abgehörten damit sie nicht zu
heiß sind für ich probiert weiß sagen
was ich habe ich habe den usa verklagt
und der anwalt sagt ist der pool aus für
mich okay ich probier mal ich mag das
ich kenne es übrigens schon und ich muss
jetzt sagen apfel lebt sauerkraut hätte
keiner gedacht das ist so genial
schmidtner pillen sagt dazu es ist
wirklich genial werden heftig mag ja
richtig gut
ich habe sachen gesagt man kann ja auch
noch so klein machen oder becken wir
allerdings speck essen ja ganz schön
viel sauerkraut sind ja auch wirklich
noch hätte dieser aufmarsch und vor
man muss dann will ich man muss kein
fleisch mehr rein machen aber ich werde
noch mal getoppt nicht aber schmeckt
richtig lecker bitte probiert ist man
sich mal fragen ob das produkt
platzierung ist natürlich kennen doch
alle dass kommen oder gar nichts auf
jeden fall sollte der rote äpfel kaufen
und diese apfel rosen aus problems in
stuttgart ich habe über so keinen
kennengelernt den ich nicht geschmeckt
hat das natürlich auch sagen es echt
schon oft gemacht ja nicht ich muss echt
sagen so eine zeit lang hatte ich nie
blätter tag daheim weil ich gedacht habe
mini wenig blätterteig macht man es
selber jetzt habe ich doch immer
meistens noch blätterteig damit ich dir
machen haben genau die spieler für ihren
augen niemand hin wieder gesagt ich mag
nachgedacht
deswegen war ich gehöre jetzt steht
wollte darüber gesehen
ich möchte damit wie die jungs draußen
gerne viel probiert das rezept gern mal
aus wir machen erst noch fotos man
kriegt raus und dann postet gerne und
ich bin schon gespannt wie sie euch
schmecken
also viel spaß beim nachbacken bis zum
nächsten mal das schreiben was er am
liebsten aus blätterteig macht genau und
abonniert den kanal dass es kein video
mehr
japan kainsmal von dir macht sonst
besser
[Musik]